Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
La feuille d'automne emportée par le vent.
En rondes monotones tombe en tourbillonnant.
Bon, je sais je ne chante pas très bien et en plus
c'est une vieille chanson mais je trouvais que
c'était une excellente entrée en matière vous
parler des feuilles des arbres, qui à l'automnechangent de couleur.
Et là, c'est un festival.
Parfois,elles deviennent jaunes comme les feuilles
de mon abricotier.
Parfois, elles deviennent oranges,
comme cet érable du Japon.
Ou roses comme les feuilles de ce fusain.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ça finirapour tout le monde de la même manière : totalement dénudée
Ça mérite un éclairage.
Ça tombe bien.
C'est un peu une histoire de lumière.
Merci les petites mains.
Commençons par mettre un peud'ordre dans toutes
ces couleurs.
Le vert d'abord. Une couleur vitale pour les arbres.
Les feuilles,vertes, fonctionnent un peu comme de petites usines.
Elles produisent des sucres que l'on retrouve
dans la sève dite élaborée
qui circule ensuite dans l'arbre, dans le tronc
et dans les branches ce qui lui permet de se développer.
Pour cela, elle capte du dioxyde de carbone, le fameux co2
présent dans l'atmosphère.
Ça, c'est les petites mains.
Elles utilisent aussi de l'eau et des sels
minéraux : des nitrates du phosphore du potassium
puisés dans le sol grâce aux racines, qui remontent
dans l'arbre et jusqu'aux feuilles.
La production de sève élaborée a lieu dans les cellules
spécifiques, des ateliers si vous préférez, et nécessite de l'énergie.
Oh je suis vert !
Il y a de quoi ! Les feuilles utilisent
la lumière du soleil qu'elles captent grâce à la chlorophylle,
un pigment de couleur verte.
En fait, le pigment absorbe la quasi-totalité du rayonnement
sauf le vert qui est réfléchi jusqu'à nos yeux.
Grâce à cette énergie, tous les ingrédients précédemment cités :
l'eau le dioxyde de carbone sont découpés
et les éléments sont recombinés pour produire des sucres
qui vont ensuite nourrir la plante.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la photosynthèse.
La photo quoi ?
La photosynthèse ! Il est un peu dur de la feuille...
Si la chlorophylle est aussi vitale, pourquoi les
feuilles jaunissent et finissent-elles par tomber?
Et bien tout simplement parce que ce qui est
bon en été, l'est beaucoup moins en hiver.
Les feuilles permettent aussi à l'arbre de transpirer.
L'eau puisée dans le sol au niveau des racines
ressort au niveau des feuilles.
Dans beaucoup derégions, l'hiver le sol est complètement gelé.
Impossible de faire le plein.
Sans compterque les cellules de la feuille, riches en eau
sont très fragiles.
En cas de gel, l'augmentationdu volume
liée au passage de l'état liquide à l'état solide,
les détruirait et c'est d'ailleursce qui se passe
au printemps quand il y a une gelée tardive.
L'hiver, c'est aussi la saison destempêtes.
Si les arbres gardent leurs feuilles, ils offrent
une plus grande surface de prise au vent,
ce qui les rend plus vulnérables,
ils se déracinent plus facilement.
Et puis, il y a la neige aussi.
Ça, c'est une photo de mon jardin lors du dernier épisode neigeux.
Si les arbres gardaient leursfeuilles,
toute cette neige s'y accumulerait
et les branches finiraient par rompre sous le poids
de cette neige.
Par conséquent, lorsque la durée des jours diminue
et que les températureschutent,
les arbres se mettent en mode hiver.
Ils se mettent à vivre au ralenti et à faire
des réserves.
Les échanges entre le bois et les feuilles cessent petit à petit.
Privées de ressources, les feuilles ne fabriquent plus de chlorophylle
et les éléments nutritifscontenus dans cette chlorophylle
sontrecyclés et rapatriés vers les branches
et vers le tronc.
D'autres pigments, bien présents depuis le départ à l'intérieur de
la feuille mais jusque là masqués par
la couche de chlorophylle font alors leur
apparition et c'est ce qui explique lechangement de couleur.
Le jaune et dû au xanthophylle,
un pigment que l'on retrouve également
dans le maïs et d'un jaune d'œuf.
Le orangeest lié à la présence de carotène,
le pigment, qui comme son nom l'indique, colore les carottes.
Certaines feuilles produisent de anthocyane,
le pigment qui les fait rougir.
Malheureusement, ça ne dure qu'un temps.
Le pétiole qui relie la feuille à la branche finit par se boucher,
lescellules qui le composent ne se renouvellent plus.
Elles durcissent.
L'eau et les sels minérauxne peuvent plus passer,
la feuille n'est plus alimentée, elle se dessèche et finit par tomber.
L'arbre entre alors en dormance...
Enfin pas tous !
Et de feuilles en aiguille, on en arrive auxconifères.
La plupart d'entre eux ne se dénudent pas en hiver.
On parle d'arbres à feuilles
persistantes par opposition aux arbres àfeuilles caduques.
Attention, entendons-nousbien,
ces arbres perdent aussi leurs feuilles.
Ce que nous appelons des aiguilles, comme ici,
mais pas d'un seul coup régulièrement.
Tandisque d'autres, repoussent à leur place de telle
sorte que l'arbre n'est jamais dégarni et ça, c'est très utile.
C'est un avantage considérable
pour la reprise de photosynthèse quand
les arbres poussent dans montagne.
En altitude, leprintemps est plus tardif qu'en plaine.
Il peut y avoir de la neige jusqu'au mois de
mai, elle peut recommencer à tomber dès lemois d'octobre.
La période végétative est donctrès courte.
En conservant leurs feuilles toutel'année,
la plupart des conifères peuvent donc
profiter des beaux jours dès qu'ils arrivent.
Pas la peine de faire de nouvelles feuilles, de
se remplumer pour synthétiser des sucres.
Bon bah je vais peut être pas rester planté ici moi,
j'ai des feuilles ramasser dans le jardin.
Ah oui, j'avais oublié, en automne
ily a aussi du vent.
J'ai plus qu'à tout recommencer, à bientôt.
Il y en a vraimentpour tous les goûts et j'oublie un truc.
Des feuilles qui en automne changent de couleur.
On parle de feu...Rohhh
On parle de feuilles persistantes par rapport...
A la chlorophylle, un piment... un piment !
Un pigment !
C'est un avantage considérable...
En conservant leurs feuilles toute l'année...